ich will jetzt nicht hier nicht dazu
seien steigern aber im dritten reich
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück weiter dies
dass annas bei einer folge minecraft iro
und ich bin nicht alleine sondern max
ist dabei wenn er spielt nicht mit hey
was geht ab
krankhaft sein tiere projekt ich werde
in dieser folge erst mal so meine gruppe
plane zu keiner hatte edith adelig
wollte mit tadel aufnehmen und tadel
hatte auch zeit aber tadel hat irgendwie
nicht so bock derzeitigen nicht so bock
auf vier oder so der wollte dann heute
nacht um 4 uhr aufnehmen da hatte ich
aber dann keine zeit wir ein bisschen
doof und sonst werde ich jetzt zwei
folgen mit max aufnehmen und danach mit
kilos wieder und da müssen wir etwas
ganz ganz heftiges verkünden wo ihr euch
dann alle die mäuler zerreißen könnte er
max weiß schon so ein bisschen was
gerade somit gehört habe ich nichts
sagen er hat etwas mit dem über grund
und dem untergrund zu tun also sozusagen
mit dem mittel grund einfach einfach die
mitte so ich werde mein haus ein
bisschen weiter bauen und mehr werde ich
machen
wir werden über ein thema reden was wir
gerade schon in langen langen arbeiten
vorher uns ausgesucht haben und eine
menge recherchiert haben oh ja nicht
einfach so was wir so mitbekommen haben
wir wollen nicht so opfer seien über
michael schumacher oder was für ein
scheiß auch immer jahre ist sondern wir
sind so ein bisschen rapstar wie man's
man's gewöhnt ist und wir haben heute
mal über dsds ja genau und wie gefällt
dir die sds den sohn erst mal alleine
unter menschen was ist das denn
überhaupt macht er klar was sie jetzt
der es ist also der erste ist die
schrecklichste deutsche serie malta das
stimmt sogar mit den scannern abkürzung
nicht gefunden du hast also die erste
erste ist eine show wo also das ist das
prinzip oder so scheint zumindest wo ja
wo künstlern also sängern die chance
gegeben würde dass sie dass sie
sozusagen bekanntwerden in deutschland
und superstars werden was aber oft nicht
so ganz funktioniert denn eigentlich
wird also meiner meinung nach werden die
leute einfach nur krass ausgebeutet bei
dsds und ist eigentlich eine show die
viel mehr auf unterhaltung als auch
irgendwie talent aus ist gibt der andere
chance
die sind deutlich leider bereits
beispielsweise oder sogar beides geht es
nämlich wirklich so um die stimme um das
damals schon sagt die sitzen doch sogar
am anfang immer mit dem rücken zu den
leuten oder ich weiß es gar oder ist das
alles nur mal so ein bisschen rein
geschaut aber auch nur so halb dann
immer mitbekommen aber dass auf jeden
fall die beiden sendungen ganz ganz
krass voneinander unterscheidet ist
wirklich einfach dieser fokus wieder die
leute behandelt werden die dahin kommen
und was das auch für ein publikum ist
was dahin komplett weiß ist wirklich so
da hat man dann leute die da hingehen
weil sie singen können und so was alles
und weil sie dann wirklich ne seine
karriere anstreben und eventuell schon
irgendwie gesang studiert haben oder
oder musikwissenschaftler welche und bei
dsds oder kommen da sie sun und weise
nicht da gab's da diese eine million
kellers ist mit die hagener klar da
diese die aussieht wie sonnen monstern
und dann kommt da rein und fördern wird
das damit da damit wird dann so weit
nicht so so zehn minuten oder so dieser
sendung gefüllt dann kommt ja fünf
minuten pause oder 1000 minuten die
erste essen zu 20 prozent werbung
und man ich brauche immer älter ich bin
gar nicht so viel glück aber bei dsds
das publikum hat einfach ganz anders und
ich glaube auch die leute die zuschauen
sind auch einfach anders oder als er
nichts gegen die leute die das hier
schauen und vielleicht vernünftig sind
also ich hab jetzt auch einmal
angeschaut aber nur so damit ich halt so
mitreden kann so ein bisschen was da so
vor sich geht und jetzt nicht irgendwie
weil ich jetzt sage zu heute wieder dsds
presse leben
das ist bisschen klingt ja auch echt
viel so über facebook mit von der partie
ist weil einfach diese ganzen abstürzen
menschen da sind und wie immer muss man
muss sich mal überlegen
man kommt jetzt zu dsds in dieses recall
oder wo auch immer sie sind diese show
kommt mir ja nicht einfach so es gibt
hier immer solche vorcastings nicht
gefilmt werden und müsste ich mir
überlegen warum die solche leute wie
diese minister einfach weiter lassen
nimmt man muss sie aber überlegen die
machen das einfach nur um die bloß zu
stellen und dann einfach erforderlich
für terror und den abzuknöpfen und auch
einfach für die quoten alter ihr ohne
spaß und das heißt einen platten seien
bereit wenn bei dsds nicht solche
verrückte leute werden wieder keiner
gucken weil sonst ja auch echt einfach
kacke da sitzen leute hier kann finde
ich hat für mich nicht viel mit weise
nicht der ist wer versteht nicht viel
von musik das einzige was er da bewertet
ist es aussehen und die titten
wir rollen lassen und wann haben sie
bestimmt nur ein grüppchen bushido 1
ohne witz der reihe sogar einen kleinen
gast dann irgendwie oder eine person die
da irgendwie auch da er sich vorgestellt
hat und die meinte dann soja bushido
viel besser lief das anders
und dann hat rtl danach dann sogar rtl
hat irgendwie sogar selbst geschrieben
soja bushido versus kay one hier das
video und so nur damit die dann sowas
dann irgendwie schreiben können und
einfach nur diese scheiß klatschpresse
das ist ja auch so bei der bild ist es
ja so teilweise jetzt setzen ja auch
wieder alles hier an wo ich bin noch
halb tot irgendwie von dem monster von
uns fressen hier bei der bild ist es ja
auch so dass die sich beispielsweise
wenn die bild einfach keine stories mir
hat man denken die sich einfach
irgendwas aus
so das ist auch einfach so bei dsds die
hand die wenn wenn wenn die einfach
sagen okay was können wir das so machen
wir wir engagieren aber ich wette paar
leute da sind auf jeden fall engagiert
in diesem alter die hatte sogar bei
facebook gepostet was sie dafür bekommen
hat für den auftritt der 600 noch was
euro muss sich auch ergeben dass das sie
für 600 euro sich so bloßstellen dass du
dir auf jeden fall nicht machen junge
die ganz deutschland hast die alte
sprache zu finden die zumindest mir die
kraft immer vor es sind ja echte
menschen das ist zumindest das gab ihr
auch mal sowas wie es mal ganz kurz
abzuschweifen ist darf auch mal so eine
serie und da gab's halt in der serie den
vergewaltiger ich glaube irgendwie
sonnenallee oder sonst irgendeine
charaktere der gast ein vergewaltiger in
der serie und der hat halt irgendwie so
eine reihe an vergewaltigung begangen
und die leute halt nicht verstanden dass
das einfach der charaktere in dieser
serie ist der der diese kacke gemacht
hat und haben dann denjenigen auf der
straße bedroht und alles umstellen das
ist der nicht anders geht doch und
sprach das gab es wirklich alle die an
dem bedroht und haben gesagt wenn er so
weiter macht und so und sie wollten ihn
anzeigen und wir haben ihn richtig
fertig gemacht obwohl er einfach nur ein
schauspieler ist und die ist derzeit
genauso willkommen wie das glauben
würden jetzt erst recht zum publikum
das ist echt einfach so junge werden
wenn man sich das mal so überlegt ist
auf jeden fall diese matches plett dass
ich jedes eu nötig aber das ist ohne
scheiß mich regt so was auch
mittlerweile einfach nur noch auf ich
finde es witzig wenn man sich darüber
landen so halt lustig macht und so was
alles aber wenn man das wenn man da die
ganze zeit ich meine diese leute
natürlich macht man sich über über die
weil die leute lustig das natürlich klar
aber einfach dass ich solche leute für
so einen scheiß sage ich mal verkaufen
das würde ich nie machen spaß
erster ist es einfach ein riesiger
zuhälter da wäre dann wäre mein lieb ich
weiß nicht für wie viel geld wird sogar
himmel und ich so zu stellen so wie
dieser allerdings auf jeden fall 600
euro ohne spaß 13 600 euro wird hier
eine stelle geben wie ich das machen
es muss so viel geld sein dass es einem
nicht mehr peinlich ist dass man vor die
tür geht und es ist einiges bevor du
gehst dahin jetzt du würdest da hingeht
und dann erzählt die rtl soja
steh ich da mal hin und macht so auf
geistig behindert und beleidigt alle
leute und ja uns die diese sachen hier
an und macht ihr einfach alles
vorgegeben und das ist das ist einfach
mega krass fällt es hat irgendwie auch
nicht so wirklich mit fernsehen zu tun
vor allem in deutschland sucht den
superstar und echte leute die singen
können und da hingehen und weiterkommen
das zeigen sie nicht im fernsehen
sondern nur die leute die nicht singen
können und einfach nur für diese
aufsehen erregen
dadurch dass sie einfach so total
abgründig komisch verrückt krank weil
sie nicht traumatisiert sind und dann
war die werden seite dargestellt aber
die sind echt gar nicht ist dann machen
sie auch noch mal das ist einfach so
durchdacht dann macht es auch nur so
autor scheiße sind wir demokratisch wir
lassen die leute anrufen zum bestimmen
weil hier also bezahlt mir irgendwie
einen euro oder so einen scheiß ja ich
war jetzt rächt sie machen einfach
doppelt kohle damit dass sie die leute
verkaufen
lediglich die haben doch schon mal
irgendwie so ergebnisse gefälscht glaube
ich habe ich auch mal gehört echt also
es geht ja gar nicht mehr ungestört die
machen alles einfach alles damit das
bedeutet das einfach eine korrupte
schalter das ist wirklich das ist voll
die mafia rtl rtl es einfach der grösste
absender den es gibt ich mein okay es
ist witzig wenn man sich mal so mitten
im leben anschauen was heißt witzig ist
witzig manchmal lacht sie über die
personen kaputt aber man die so die ich
weiß halt nie wie viel da man davon
glauben sollen mittlerweile glaube ich
einfach nichts mehr weil welt bei rtl
ist es so dass dieses einem mädel da
diese milliliter da die wahrheit da und
das ganze internet lacht über die was
das ganze internet alle fernsehen
deutschland lacht einfach immer möglich
weil die einfach so weise nicht die idee
ist einfach in den köpfen hängen
geblieben so bleibt hängen und rtl
kostet dann noch so screenshots von ihr
und dann soja damit die schöne alpträume
bekommt so richtig behindert einfach
spaß so einfach okay die die diese
person hat sich für die was meinst du 6
und europa verkauft
aber es ist doch auch wieder so dumm wie
kann man sich denn für 600 euro an sonne
und spaß ist dann irgendwie auch eigene
dummheit firmen so was macht aber das
ist es auch wirklich voll von dingen und
möglich kann wenn die jetzt vielleicht
irgendwie
irgendwie 600 euro braucht und dann das
aktuelle für mach ich zeit und dass das
rtl das dann so krass ausnutzt ich weiß
nicht was sie für verträge bekommen die
leute müssen wahrscheinlich
unterschreiben dass sie dass sie sich
für den verkauf ist nur sowas keine
ahnung auf ihre themen wie so was
behindert ist auf jeden fall ist das
echt hart alter wie guck mal ich google
mal mehr lister und dick oder so heißt
ja so muss es ist elisa die ok wollte
meine ganze ich mache meine rüstung
reparieren verkaufsschalter was fehlt
dir so geschrieben
ok richtig viel anscheinend ihr rtl
titelt auch bushido veen mit lisa pöbelt
gegen prinz kay one und dann packen sie
noch so ein richtig schön hässliches
bild von der ihn schön hässlichen auch
glück sie packen einfach so ein
richtiges bild von ihren dass sie alle
denkt so scheiße dies ja mega schlimmen
und sowas und ohne spaß ich finde das
nicht okay
übrigens mal ganz kurz leute danke an
den tipp da man einige ich habe immer an
breaking eins drauf gelassen wenn ich
das reparieren wollte allerdings wollen
jetzt alle dass wenn ich protection
eines drauf lasse dass das dann viel
besser ist dass das jetzt kostet nämlich
noch ein repair kos das ist mega gut
danke an die playoffs verpasst wenn man
wenn was repariert ja ist es halt so es
gibt hier so op rüstungen das sind so
scale erkenne ich kenne ich so gerne auf
jeden kennt und wenn man da die sachen
reparieren will dann am 2
ja aber du wenn du die ganzen sachen
drauf was wie es beispielsweise an
breaking oder sold at oder protection
kostet reparieren halt irgendwann 50
level oder so aber du kannst es einfach
wieder runter verzaubern dann kriegt
halt wieder die level wo du musst eine
verzauberung darauf lassen darauf lassen
und ich habe immer an breaking eins
drauf gelassen aber das hat dann immer
irgendwie 7 gekostet aber wenn man
protection eins drauf lässt kostet
irgendwo ein zu lassen und deswegen habe
ich jetzt sechs erfahrungen im
schwimmbad wahrscheinlich beim
protection einst auch mit einer auf
level 1 verzaubern kann
es gibt aus italien team hinten die auch
dass ich das drauf packen marktaktivität
hast du denn schon gute rüstung und so
ja aber ich traue mich aber nie so einen
kampf zu gehen weil ich möchte ihn ganz
zu halten eigentlich nichts tun
liebst du sie zu sehr auf jeden fall
wenn kollegen kannst du fertig mache bis
jemand auf dem server eines drauf ich
glaube ich wird jetzt sogar den angriff
also meine rüstung ist eigentlich
relativ gut ausgerüstet mit mein schwert
ich weiß nicht was ich da noch viel
drauf packen soll irgendwie finde ich
weiß was ich verzaubern sondern ich
glaub ich bin trotzdem schlecht
aufgestellt weil ich halt nicht diese
ganzen dings habe ich habe ja nicht 1000
herzen so wie die anderen junge ich sehe
gerade ich hab mir gerade eben mir lisa
orange google gesundheits weiß weißt du
was die bild kostet sie schreibt
irgendwas die letzten kommen und dann
irgendwas über die junge die lesben
kommen sie schreibt die schreiben
einfach so selbst was folgendes alter
und was ich hab's ich habe jedoch
gezeigt habe wie lange ist die folge bis
jetzt zwölf minuten
da können wir noch das andere thema
anschneiden oder mit fler und bushido ja
kann man auch machen und zwar wir sind
jetzt ein bisschen bei medien und die
nächste frage wird die anderen darüber
handeln und ich bin ja noch was anderes
gestoßen habe ich mir auch gedacht zu
der bild zeitung sind auch ganz schlau
und zwar hat der mz mb sind ganz schlaue
menschen die redakteure der düssel bild
zeitung wir richtig stark
ein hd extra und bushido weißt ja wie
bushido wird ja wie bestimmt jeder von
euch weiß so richtig fertig gemacht von
der bild-zeitung und bisher immer gegen
bushido und schreibt irgendwas der
hassprediger droht unschuldige
umzubringen beschlossen
das ist einfach die bild zeitung und die
abschiede und rapper weiß bestimmt jeder
und dann habe ich grade eben was gelesen
über fler und auf einem schreiben flair
das rapide ich ja mal was jetzt los
und warum ist klären rapido weil er bei
den attentaten sozusagen offen
ausgebildet und leute ihn umbringen
wollte also es ist einfach bitter das
ist einfach
einfach keinen sinn ja und ich behindert
sobald ihr mann gebracht wird bushido
oder nochmal dargestellt bushido taliban
hass prediger ein mörder das alles ist
einfach ungefähr alles was schlecht
rassist rassist okay und sobald jemand
irgendwie ja keine ahnung irgendwie
einer schlechten position ist in seinem
leben so irgendwie ein verwandter ist
gestorben oder sowas geben die einfach
einen fake drauf legt beziehung das ja
der arme flair bla bla bla bla bla und
spaß denn wenn du nichts passiert wäre
die würden dinge genau so nennen wie
bushido einfach weil die voll hetzen das
ist mega krass ich weiß ich weiß auch
einfach nicht wie viel dann damit zu tun
hat oder ob das einfach dann die bild
zeitung ist das ist halt auch so wieder
die sache weil das ist ja bei rtl auch
so dass einfach man muss sagen es ist ja
so es gibt irgendwie so drei mächte im
staat glaube ich werden das malen sowie
das online sowie ein politik vor 1000
jahren mal einen sechsten klasse oder so
und die medien entwickeln sich immer
weiter zu
zur vierten macht quasi im staat wodurch
man quasi das volk beeinflussen kann das
sind dann irgendwie reden wenn du meinst
exekutive judikative genau und dann
medien ja das kann sein ja familien sind
entwickeln weil wir durch die medien
kannst du so viel beeinflussen allein
das was jetzt mit links hier passiert
ist allein sagen wir mal rtl ist zwar
ein blödes beispiel aber es ist halt
wirklich einfach so das mega der hass
auf einmal geschoben wird auf bestimmte
leute oder bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen
oder irgendwie sowas ist einfach weiß
nicht ich weiß nicht was ich davon
halten soll
und ich weiß auch nicht also die sender
ja ok sollen die man ruhig machen aber
auch das publikum das dass wir quasi uns
beeinflussen lassen weil es ist so krass
dass ich will jetzt nicht hier nicht
dazu seien reinsteigern aber im dritten
reich
hörbach alles einfach jetzt ich verbinde
das mit allem auch mit der welt welt
klimaerwärmung nie aber das ist ja das
ist auf jeden fall so dass man durch die
medien so was von leute einfach
beeinflussen kann ist aber du hast
eigentlich recht es ist ja eigentlich
nichts anderes als propaganda es ist er
ja es ist nichts anderes als propaganda
weil es wird einfach jeder gleich
dargestellt und die menschen werden
einfach so beeinflusst und das ist
einfach einfach so heftigen darauf
sollte man auch aufpassen sollte einfach
wirklich nicht den ganzen scheiß glauben
den rtl ein paket und so vor allem jetzt
jetzt mal auf aus einer bezogen
natürlich gibt es statistiken die sagen
dass ausländer das bei weitem nicht bei
straftaten an erhöhte prozentuale anzahl
an ausländer meistens daran beteiligt
bzw schuldig gesprochen wird
allerdings wird noch mal durch rtl so
martin mitten im leben oder so wo er
hauptsächlich echt ausländische familien
dann irgendwie sind die dann irgendwie
im ghetto wohn und dann wo die kinder
ihre mütter schlag und alles möglich da
geht's ja videos von trainer andreas
psychiatrie als nährstoff der deutschen
aber es wäre halt immer solche leute
dargestellt und ich weiß einfach nicht
was man davon halten soll obwohl die
quasi brauch ich habe schon 13 obsidian
ich dachte die ganze ich hab s 9
aber dadurch wird hat quasi dieses
dieses schlechte licht auf die quasi
gelenk mehr oder weniger und dadurch
auch ein ganz ganz gutes beispiel
gamescom 2012 rtl bericht über gamer die
ganze welt die rtl schaut man auf einmal
so hardy gamer die stinken alle die sind
total dürfen da wird direkt ein
stereotyp dann wieder erzeugte scheiße
aussieht du stimmst du auch
das ist echt das ist echt heftig also
ist auch wirklich so gemeint ist ja dass
medien immer mehr einfluss haben
wenn man sich jetzt mir überlegt diese
ganze axel-springer-konzern dem gehören
ja wirklich viele zeitungen und dem was
haben jetzt noch mal gekauft n tv n24
gehört und für alles hier in deutschland
was mich angeht
und wenn einfach dieser konzern zu dem
auch die bild zeitung gehört und was
weiß ich auch vielleicht fernsehsender
mit der jetzt einfach vor den
bundestagswahlen sagen würde
die npd ist so richtig gut und keine
ahnung so viele ausländer in deutschland
die machen alles kaputt in sowas wenn
einfach dieser konzern das sagen würde
ich glaube dann wird die npd im
bundestag kommt
ganz einfach weil so viele leute sie
harmlos teil wieder überlegen wie
aufgeklärt sind wir eigentlich da muss
man dann wieder auf mit einer ganz ganz
anderen china ankommen weil das ist dann
wieder so die sache jetzt wenn wenn wenn
wenn wir das jetzt zu sagen und wir
haben sage ich jetzt mal vernünftige
zuschauern den kommentaren die sich
eventuell ein bisschen auskennen
die sagen dann ja so was wie damals da
1901 1940 um den dreh oder wird er nicht
wieder vorkommen dass wir noch viel zu
aufgeklärt und soja ja klar
natürlich wenn sich dann irgend so einer
vorne hinstellt und mais soja wir wollen
krieg und wir sind die besten und sodann
dann merkt man das natürlich aber wenn
da einfach so dass so unterschwellig
betrieben wird das dann auch einmal zum
beispiel immer mehr sogar längeren
prozess auf einmal ganz viele zeitungen
meinen soja die npd die als tolle ziele
und die wollen dies machen und die
wollen das machen dann und findet dass
eventuell passiert also jetzt nicht
unbedingt dann gegen juden wieder
sondern dann eventuell halt wirklich
einfach in deutschland gegen ausländer
weil die ausländer haben ja einfach ein
schlechtes bild zurzeit wird das wir
könnten sind das einfach nur durch die
medien ich kenne selbst genug ausländer
die einfach mega korrekt sind und dieses
schlechte bild wird einfach nur es läuft
wirklich so sind wirklich diese
stereotypen wie du gesagt hast die
einfach komplett schlecht geredet werden
das heißt jetzt nicht dass wir sowas
wollen dass wir so eine propaganda
irgendwie abzielen damit das jetzt so
was kommt aber wenn so was kommt leute
seid aufgeklärt und schwimmt gegen den
strom und die erinnert euch an erinnert
euch ein kräfte gebracht da wird dann so
der kopf der revolution machen wir
kräfte und da laufen wir mit mistgabeln
gegen axel springer natürlich gut meine
freunde dass er die folge ist vorbei wir
sind genau passend jetzt bei 20 minuten
ich glaub ich schon mal aus wir werden
die nächste folge auch über eine andere
show auf rtl reden ihr könnt ja schon
mal raten lassen es ist schreibt sich
die kommentare
mit de an
das rät gewinnen mein herz ja der
gewinnt ein schweine herz wir haben
schweineherzen musiziert ehrlich der am
kit wir haben nie irgendwas sie ziehe
noch nie
diego ich habe aus dem schweine herbst
mit drei feldern herz herausgeschnitten
wenn es euch gefallen hat könnt ihr eine
bewertung da lassen schreibt mir eure
meinung zu dem thema eine kommentare und
sagen sie uns